so you've partnered with your brother
Wladimir on the film and you know you
know his strengths and weaknesses and
you know how well Merson or pressure if
you were to start from scratch and
choose someone here would you choose
someone like you or some a totally
opposite I to somebody with the entirely
different does skill sets yeah that's
because are there so many things that I
hate doing like what like selling a
movie talking good about your movie
again people Pumped Up about I'm
horrible at it you know I think I mean
sales you know what Brando said acting
his sales and you know I have respect
for I think it's almost a talent it's
not even a skill it's like who knows how
to sell become Steve Jobs you know it's
and I'm you know I'm for you guys about
the movie i would tell you really
vaguely what's it about and you'd
probably sit probably some crap but if
you ask my brother he would make you
think that's the only thing missing in
your life you know and you need those
guys like he started business in
management and here's that guy who will
come in start selling you off the bat I
mean he could cuz that's what he does
and you know I undersell so you like to
be more sort of the realist may be
working alone you're more better like
that where some people are just more
that extrovert that's able to go and
work a room yeah well yeah yeah yeah
just I I know it was never comfortable
with you know working the room mingling
you know because I don't know I see all
these sides to it and I always feel
silly there's a line in my film where
character says the only time I really
bored was that when I'm around with
people I don't really know try to make
polite conversation you know it's kind
that's parties you know and I got a but
I like as far as film I started drawing
comic books since I was you know able to
pick up a pen so since 78 they started
publishing my comic books in the
newspaper we can use weight but they pay
me books in Serbia so time came from
film school it did sir well as a as a
background like film directing and comic
books very close
but that's that's kind of what
uncomfortable a guy could draw comic
books its most of the time nada guy you
know talking up at the party stuff do
you ever feel a pressure to do that to
kind of hang out hey guys were one of
the bar afterwards for an after party
and you know that in some sense that's a
great way to bond with PJ no but if
you're like those of us who maybe have a
little bit of social anxiety or they're
just not you can't get really deep in a
while and talk about meaningful stuff
it's usually sometimes promises that
don't write manifest yeah I saw this
great phone call indie game the movie
you see it all right those guys are
awesome and you know they've done it
there's something spiring as far as oh
wow I haven't tweeted I'm like so the
Java Sea he's like not only for things
that we knew we couldn't sound like you
know TV channel in Brazil but anyways in
the movie one of the creators of one of
the game says I would like to connect
with people without having to meet him
so it's uh I mean you know I'm not a
missing Trump or anything a lot of
people but III the aspect of schmoozing
and kind of man that I it's really hard
like it's time for me to to put on the
smile and then I worked at a hotel it's
harming the hotel you have to be
Carolina you know I get it in LA has a
lot of smiley pretty happy jobs that you
have to do it and that's great and I met
people who uh who are like that like
they're just positive and they love
smiling de la being friendly and I have
this kind of gloomy you know cloud most
of the time and it's really hard for me
to be always at all times hi how you
doing when I don't mean it you know I
mean one of those things but don't you
think in some sense that's what makes
your storytelling so excellent because
you're able to tap in to some feelings
that a lot of people don't want they
don't want to go there they don't want
to talk about that while the critics
shell wrote the nice review of the film
and it's one that was all the things
like the protagonist in your film is you
know he's not a nice person and we don't
like him and that's really where that
that is the guy that
supposed to spend two hours with in a
story that you know you want to try to
find out you know something likeable
about I mean you do hopefully you know
help him find a piece of humanity but I
am attracted to flawed people I remember
a story and I read this somewhere a
Greek first time I like I'm trying to
grease and you know one of those party
notes the story is one of the Greek
consoles ordered a wisdom to be you know
coined by the seven philosophers they
can put and the entrance of the temple
they will remain for generations and
generations to come and the other i will
think about this really hard and they
came up and the one did the one that
they came up with what they came up with
was a man is flawed that's and now is
remembered and and I think it's great
that you're able to say it with no shame
because I mean look at some of the great
rock and roll you know Janice job and
all these people that are so amazingly
creative Jim Morrison and also the
demons that they've out there you know
if you're just one-dimensional and never
reach those depths of spare then how
would you ever create any kind of an
emotional piece of art yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's so
you